these are very valuable lessons that we
need in our relationships so lesson one
the bestelling author the modern
philosopher of love his goal to help you
live a better more meaningful life the
average human has 70,000 thoughts a day
the problem is that we don't know how to
use them for example we tend to believe
we'll find the one but that belief has
led to more rage more disappointment cuz
we're not free to love just anyone
what's problematic is that we're drawn
to love stories that are echoing our
childhoods and this is something that
troubles so many people because our past
was not necessarily happy we are all
confused about love the most romantic
sentence that people will say is I met
this person and we didn't even need to
speak we just felt on the same page but
this leads to a catastrophic outbreak of
sulking they say to you is anything
wrong of course there is but you're not
going to tell them and the reason is
that you're a romantic and you believe
that your partner should have alien
capacities to look into your wounded
soul to understand what the upset is but
of course they can't because they're
just human so what would you say are the
core habits of two people who have a
really successful relationship what we
need is Let's Talk About Sex Goodness Me
does it cause problems 26% of people in
relationships are having sex less than
10 times per year so the question is
what are we getting wrong one of the
leading answers that neither party knows
is there is that ding- Ding that's
normally a sign of a
problem quick one this is really really
fascinating to me on the back end of our
YouTube channel it says that
69.9% of you that watch this channel
frequently over the lifetime of this
channel haven't yet hit the Subscribe
button I just wanted to ask you a favor
it helps this channel so much if you
choose to just subscribe helps us scale
the guest helps us scale the production
and it makes this show bigger so if I
could ask you for one favor if you've
watched the show before and you've
enjoyed it and you like this episode
that you're currently watching could you
please hit hit the Subscribe button
thank you so much and I will repay that
gesture by making sure that everything
we do here gets better and better and
better and better that is a promise I'm
willing to make you do we have a
[Music]
deal
Alan you write about so much you produce
content about so many different subject
matters but what is the overarching
mission that you are on I trying to look
almost systematically at a variety of
causes of unhappiness created by the
world we live in um you know obviously
the world we live in has solved many
many problems but it's also generated in
a host of areas particularly um
difficult challenges that have not
really struck Humanity before and I like
to think both personally and on behalf
of others um about what those problems
are and how we might steer through them
the average human has 70,000
thoughts a day right not huge elaborate
ones but just stray little fragmentary
thoughts 70,000 of them pass through
Consciousness every day and the problem
is that we don't know how to process
them or use them this is part of the
reason why we end up with such you know
busy and troubling Minds we haven't
stepped back in order to ask ourselves
at the end of the day some of those
questions that can calm us down like you
know who am I angry with what am I
excited by
what's really happened today you know we
let experiences Rush past us and then of
course experiences that haven't been
digested properly have a nasty habit of
coming to sting Us in the tail um and I
think you can look at a lot of mental
troubles is essentially the outgrowth of
unprocessed emotion um you know
depression is often sadness that hasn't
understood itself anxiety
or irritability is worry that doesn't
know its own cause and so often what we
need particularly in the modern world is
occasions on which we can get to know
our own minds it's it's a it's a strange
thing surely we know our own minds
surely we know no no the way that we're
built is obviously not prioritizing a
full awareness of ourselves we're
outward facing creatures we're action
focused creatures which is all the good
and has many advantages but because of
the way we live now more sedentary lives
lives that call upon us not merely to be
active but also to be
fulfilled um those lives require periods
of introspection that are routines often
don't allow for so I'm always trying
both of myself and Advising others you
know take that time in the evening and
just sit down in a semi darkened room
and just ask yourself what's coming up
for me what's really happened inside me
because it can take a little while to
realize what you're really upset by what
you're really excited by Etc we're not
obvious to ourselves and as I say so
many of things that we call mental
disorders or mental illnesses are really
stored emotion that hasn't found a way
out emotions that haven't been
acknowledged have a nasty habit of um
stirring our conscience demanding to be
heard they might want to tell our spines
they might want to tell our stomachs you
know and again a useful exercise so as
not to be struck by so many of these
psychosomatic disorders is to ask the
body what it's trying to tell you so
that it doesn't need to tell you in the
more dramatic forms that end up as
illnesses so again if you you know if
you lie down you simply say to yourself
if my back could speak what does it want
to tell me if my shoulders could have
their say what are they trying to say if
my stomach could have a voice what might
it be trying to utter can you apply that
same rationale to things like anxiety
absolutely you know if you think of take
something like insomnia right you wake
up at 3 in the morning the way I like to
think of it is insomnia is if you like a
kind of Revenge for all those thoughts
that you were so careful not to have in
the day you very carefully schemed not
to have those thoughts in the day
because of our emotional conscience they
want to be heard and if you're not
hearing them at 3:00 p.m. you're going
to be hearing them at 3:00 a.m. and so
you know one of the best ways to sleep
is to make sure you're having a little
bit more of an in-depth conversation
with yourself before you enter sleep
because that will allow you that kind of
deeper rest so as I say we have this
emotional conscience that requires that
the key things about us have a chance to
be heard and look let's not forget I
mean this is the whole theory of trauma
you know what psychotherapists have very
usefully over the last 2030 years
informed us about is that um events in
our past especially in our early
childhood that we have not had a chance
to properly understand and how much can
a 3 four five six year old understand
events that we can't understand um it
doesn't mean that they haven't
registered they've registered all the
more deeply and they haven't had a
chance to be processed you know I I was
thinking friend of mine recently lost a
parent he's in his 50s well educated got
resources got friends spouse Etc he was
telling me he was laid Low by depression
just couldn't get out of bed completely
stunned by his loss and I was thinking
in a way he's lucky because he's got all
those resources of adulthood imagine a
5-year-old child who suffers a
bereavement they've got no friends that
they can have those sort of dialogues
with they've got no books that they can
re read about this they've got no
capacity to process they've got no
understanding of time Etc um emotions
that can't be had lodged themselves in
us and gum up our systems and um I think
so much of the work that we need to do
on ourselves is to process pain that has
not been properly understood not because
anyone's evil but because we've lacked
the resources to do
so you got me thinking about this
concept of Happiness as you're speaking
and whether it's a
natural thing for our species to be
aiming at or whether it's a new more
modern thing that we've decided to focus
upon and are we causing oursel immense
distress in this pursuit of this thing
that maybe our ancestors didn't didn't
ever think about this whole you know we
think about self-actualization and they
were probably thinking about survival
and reproduction more look these all
belong to the sort of paradoxes of
modern times modern times have obviously
brought us enormous advantages but
they've also brought us particular
complexities that I think we'd be wise
to to realize and one of them is The
Disappearance of religion I mean we are
still among the first Generations in
many parts of the world to be um trying
to live good lives without the support
of religion think of how religion's
structure time and Human Experience in
time as a religious person you
immediately feel the present moment is
not as important as 100 200 2,000
million year history that has come
before and that will continue after the
present moment is a speck in time and
and there's a whole Narrative of which
you're part of that immediately
diminishes you in scale now nowadays all
of us want to be rather large we want to
be big big people we want to make a big
impression but um arguably this is a
fast route to mental illness because the
graceful acceptance of your miniscule
position in the cosmos is the gateway to
calm and harmony
and when people say you know I went into
this hotel you know the person made me
feel small that's the bad way of being
made to feel small but there's a good
way of being made to feel small pick up
an ancient text read words that were
written by someone in a foreign tongue
3,000 years ago that'll make you feel
small go into the desert notice the the
age of the Rocks inscribed in you know
time inscribed in sand that'll put you
in your place um spend time with an
animal that has no concern for your
state
your sense of importance your foiled
Narrative of your own success all these
things that drive modern humans mad
these are not present in an older kind
of religious sphere and as I say what
religions do is they tell us you're part
of a bigger story they also tell us many
faiths tell us that life and you
particular are imperfect um you know
think of Catholicism and its notion of
original sin now lots of lots of bad
stuff associated with with original sin
I'm not you know a huge fan of many
aspects but let's look at the good side
right what it what Catholicism tells is
that everybody's broken everybody is
flawed it's quite a helpful starting
point right because um if you think well
all right I'm bit broken but so's
somebody else so's somebody else so
we're all doing our best that's the
gateway to vulnerability to Friendship
if you like lower expectations lower
expectations but also to to connection
with others you know so often people who
become successful F find it really hard
to make friends why because they
associate success with invulnerability
and the more successful they get the
harder it is for them to admit to the
real truth about being human which is
that we're all helpless children some of
the time at least frightened helpless
children and it becomes harder to make
to keep up the contact with that let
alone admit that to somebody else so
again religions handily reduce our
expectations and our sense of ourselves
we are merely flawed humans there is a
perfect world it doesn't exist in
Beverly Hills it doesn't exist in you
know the fancy parts of Singapore or or
Sydney it exists up there in a in
another world in other words um the
human realm is inherently imperfect
quite a good starting point I mean even
if you went on a date right imagine two
characters you might go on a date with
right first one tells you yeah I'm kind
of perfect and I'm achieve I'm aiming to
achieve total Perfection think wow good
for them but slightly scary next to
somebody else who goes I'm kind of
flawed but I'm sort of managing my flaws
and I'm interested in how to get to know
my flaws and work with them instantly
one thinks H life might be easier around
such a person there's there's something
about the pursuit of perfection which
makes day-to-day life extremely hard and
religions slightly by The Bu tick that
box they were able to reduce us in our
own eyes while raising us in the eyes of
you know a Divine being um and and that
has helped us to have an that helped us
to have an easier relationship with with
ourselves and and the notion also was
you cannot perfect this life you know
life becomes perfect in another realm
we'll build Jerusalem somewhere else not
on this Earth in the next world again it
takes the pressure off us we moderns we
modern people we think the present
moment is supremely important now is
important everything that's going on
right now is supremely important doesn't
matter remember 100 years ago a thousand
years ago now is the only criteria of
time you are perfect right so if there's
something wrong with you you're failing
against an ideal of perfection again
very very hard um and that you are made
I mean the biggest the biggest challenge
of all you're made to be happy as you
suggested that the true goal of every
human is happiness not fulfillment not
you know the realization of a grand
scheme not living for others your own
happiness and again it's a beautiful
idea but Goodness Me does it cause
problems goodness me you know think of
Emil
durkheim beginning of the 20th century
French sociologist writes this book um
so contrasting the differences between
ancient societies and modern societies
and he identifies one troubling
difference between ancient societies
premodern agricultural village-based
societies where religion plays a role
and Modern urban technologically driven
success oriented individualistic
societies and that's the suicide rate he
realizes in his book on suicide
published in 1900 that modern societies
for all their advantages leads their
members of a share of their members
often the most ambitious of their
members to take their own lives why
what's going on and this becomes well
it's the birth of modern sociology
really it's it becomes a major inquiry
into what modern times does to the soul
and I'm deeply fascinated by that I
can't let that one go because what's
this Paradox what's this Paradox of
suffering amidst plenty of regress
amidst progress this fascinates me I
spoke to the CEO of calm campaign
against living miserably Simon gunning
and he shared some stats with me about
exactly what you're talking about about
suicide he said someone dies by suicide
in the UK every 90 minutes 76% a male
there's 25 attempts for every death um
the single biggest cause of death for
men under 45 is suicide single biggest
cause of death for 15 to 49 year olds is
suicide that 19 to 35y Old category are
twice as likely to report being in
crisis than any other group and 16 to
24s is the fastest growing group in
history to exhibit suicidality and more
recently there's a big conversation
emerging now around young women and
suicidality which is um a fairly recent
unfortunately exploding Trend this trend
of young women now experiencing
suicidality and look people don't just
commit suicide when things are bad
people commit suicide when things are
bad and they think it's a delicate point
they think it's their fault they cannot
disassociate the trouble they feel from
an intense sense of responsibility which
then also entails shame now what's going
on there you see when I say that we live
in a individualistic world what that
really means is we live in a world where
people feel that they control their own
narratives that that what happens to
them is very tightly a reflection of who
they are and what they've done and this
was not always the case you see for long
periods of History um people were not
necessarily tightly held to the
observable outcomes of their lives this
happened with money for example um in
Old
English a poor person was known as an
unfortunate right um what is an un let's
unpack that word unfortunate there's the
word Fortuna in there what was Fortuna
for the Romans Fortuna was the goddess
of luck the goddess of Fortune and the
Romans were there all the time
sacrificing things to the goddess of
Fortune as a way of saying you know
please you know it's not me it's you
know this Outside Agency nowadays this
sounds completely weird I mean what do
we
call in the most individualistic country
in the world United States what are poor
people called it's not a nice term
they're called losers right you say
that's a loser so we've gone from
unfortunate to Loser that's a trajectory
of 400 years what's happened in that
time is a story about who's responsible
for people's fate and nowadays you know
if I said to you Stephen things have not
been going so well for me I've just been
sacked uh you know my my book haven't
sold you know but it's not me I just had
a bit of bad luck you very nice person
but a modern person side of you'd be
thinking H you must have done something
wrong right you'd be think you must done
something wrong because that's how we
think we don't allow people the benefit
of luck right similarly if you said to
me oh you know my podcast be doing
brilliantly we've now got 8,000 million
million billion subscrib how many you
got nowadays um um and and you said and
you said to me oh I just just a bit of
good luck right I think oh Steph's
really you know he's very modest but you
know it's not true he's done something
we believe that people do things and
that that action leads to results or
failures and that's why people take
their own lives because in extremists
people think there is nothing other than
me to explain what happens to me of
course the reality is much more
complicated I'm not saying that's the
truth but that is the perceived truth
you know look we live in a world that is
meritocratic right that word
meritocracy is on everybody's lips if
you put take politicians left and right
in the United States all over the world
everybody wants to create a world that
is meritocratic some people think we've
already got there what does that word
mean I don't know meritocratic is the
concept of meritocracy is a a world in
which um
people's outcomes are dependent on their
Merit rather than on who their parents
were um some corrupt class in society
the influence of whatever so you know a
left-wing politician and a right-wing
politician say we want to make a
meritocratic world where your kids will
go to where they deserve where if you
work hard you can get there and um you
know where everyone has a chance to
succeed you know you know that kind of
rhetoric it's it's the rhetoric of
modern times
now it sounds great and in many ways
it's an enormous advance but again let's
just focus on the psychological toll of
that because if you really believe in a
world in which those who get to the top
deserve to get to the top by implication
you are also positing the existence of a
world in which those who are at the
bottom deserve to be at the bottom in
other words a meritocratic worldview
turns success and failure from chance to
a necessary fate and that's why it makes
the winners quite hard potentially quite
heartless because they're thinking well
I got there on my own you know don't
need to thank anybody might not need to
pay many taxes why why pay taxes you
know it's fine and similarly those at
the bottom are kind of crushed so we
we've created this very complicated
ideology where
um there's a hidden toll what is love
let's if we're talking about let's talk
about romantic love what is
that well can I just first start by
saying we're bit confused about it and
and so I can't give you an immediate
answer but I want to register that not
just me but the whole of the current
world is confused about love and I think
we've been confused for about 200 years
and and let's let's go easy on ourselves
here because
the way in which we approach Love Now is
a
neverbe um approached philosophy you
know for about the last 250 years we've
been loving under the eges of a
philosophy we could call
Romanticism and Romanticism is is a
vision of love with very particular
assumptions let me run through a few of
them um there's one soulmate for
everybody you're going to find this
soulmate um you're going to find them
through slightly mysterious ways
possibly through almost something almost
quasi Divine like you'll feel pulled
you'll meet them at the supermarket
checkout line the nightclub and without
even knowing too much about them you
will sense that they're your destiny so
you'll feel impelled towards somebody
that you don't necessarily know too much
of a a force will pull you and you will
feel this is the one and there will be
an angel literally a sort of descended
being from from another Another World um
The Romantics were very very keen on on
the notion that you didn't have to know
someone too well to understand them even
speaking not very much the connection
would be even deeper um The Romantics
also thought that love and sex
absolutely belong together and that that
you couldn't have a millimeter of
disjunction between the two love and sex
had sometimes drifted apart in the old
world and that had been sometimes a
problem but it became a tragedy so
adultery moved from a difficulty to a
tragedy that's where all modern novels
and films are all about the tragedy of
of adultery so look these are some of
the difficulties that the modern world
has created we we tend to believe
nowadays that love is an emotion that we
should feel never a skill that we should
learn you know for example if I said to
you we should probably study love we
should probably go to a school of love
you go that's not very romantic now
every time every time that someone says
that's not very romantic ding-ding
that's normally a sign of a problem like
most things that don't sound very
romantic are a good idea and most things
that are romantic like marrying in Vegas
after you've met someone for 5 minutes
is not so great
now what are we getting wrong one of the
things we're getting wrong is this whole
business of instinct right so we tend to
believe that love will pull us
instinctively towards marvelous people
that will be correct for us you know the
old world people were set up in
relationships you'll marry this person
because of this reason you know that
person goes well with with my family
blah blah in other words nothing to do
with you you you're put together with
somebody nowadays we're nominally free
to choose anyone hooray fantastic aren't
we going to make great choices uh no why
don't we make great choices because
we're not free why are we not free we
need to go to psychotherapist to tell us
why we're not free we're not free to
love just anyone we love in tracks laid
down for us by our
childhoods adult love sits on top of
tracks and a script laid down for us in
childhood you might go what's the
problem with that so what well what's
problematic is that many of us had
childhoods in which affection was mixed
in with more problematic dynamics that
maybe in order to derive love in
childhood we also had to encounter
somebody who was in a rage someone who
was violent someone who was depressed
someone who put us down someone who
preferred another sibling whatever it
was and we go into adulthood and we find
that we're drawn to love stories that
feel familiar because they're echoing
some of childhood Dynamics but they
don't necessarily for that matter lead
to happiness and you know sometimes we
have situations
where you set up a friend let's say you
got a really good friend and you know
another friend you think those people
would really go well together you set
them up on a date and then you call them
up afterwards you say how did it go you
know it must have gone really well they
say I'm not sure maybe something was
lacking a little spark what they're
really trying to get at is they're not
going to put it this way your friend
this date did not show me signs that
they would make me suffer in the way
that I need to suffer in order to feel
I'm in love in other words this
relationship threatened to be happy
that's why I had to go away so we are
paradoxical creatures because our past
was not necessarily happy we're not
necessarily that happy that our future
romantic lives should be happy either
and this is something that you know they
they weren't thinking about that When
Love Was reinvented 250 years ago when
people say they have daddy issues and
things like this are you saying then
that there's often truth in that because
they had a early experience with a
father figure a male figure in their
life that might have left them or might
have you know created a anxious
attachment style or something so they
then end up pursuing dysfunctional men
and relationships because that's the
suffering that they associate with love
sure I mean we repeat what we don't
understand and so long as we're unaware
of the stories that we've grown up with
we will enact them in our adult lives so
we're not compelled to do this forever
but and and look I think a lot of us
have a desire to give the story of our
childhood a different ending Our Father
might have been a distant and you know
mean-spirited creature but also had some
good qualities the dream is to find
somebody a bit like that but to make
sure that the story has a good
resolution so it's not merely a desire
to repeat it's a desire to repeat and
give a better ending but frequently you
know we don't get there and I think
that look the thing about psychology is
we see all around us people people doing
so-called crazy things you know falling
in love with people not going to make
them happy sabotaging their
careers not able to open up to people
and we think we can step back and go why
are they doing that stuff what's going
on now one way to look at it and it's a
kind of compassionate way to look at it
a lot of the stuff that looks crazy now
once made a lot of sense it was once
probably a really clever thing to do if
you were were growing up let's say in an
environment in which let's say a parent
was suicidal right a parent was
suicidal and you shut down your emotions
totally and decided you would never
trust anyone fantastic that's a
fantastically clever thing to do when
you're 5 years old and you've got a
suicidal parent right because that will
get you through to the next stage of
life if you open your heart at five and
there's a parent who's suicidal it'll
tear you apart so good for you you're
you're doing something brilliantly
clever right or imagine somebody who um
is a becomes a clown as a child because
there's a very sad atmosphere and
there's a depression and all they can
have time for is jokes they're just a
manic Joker right brilliant what what a
fantastic thing for a kid to work out
that they need to be quite a kind of
manic Joker but what happens 10 years
later 20 years later 30 years later is
that what used to be a fantastic defense
against an intolerable situation has
turned out to more or less ruin people's
chances because the person you know with
that difficult father will end up never
being able to open their heart to anyone
even a very safe person they won't even
know their heart's closed but they will
be acting out the same defensive
strategy or the person who you know it
was a great idea to be a bit of a joker
early on but now they have no time for
anything serious and their friends feel
that they're a slightly plastic person
can never connect with them that's a
real toll in in in the in the adult
world so you know very often what we
need to do is to say thank you to our
younger selves for having devised
strategies that really were clever but
at the same time say thank you it's
enough I want I want to live in a
different way that was a fantastic
strategy then it may no longer be the
right way for me to live now I was
thinking as you were speaking about that
that there's kind of two groups of
people I was bouncing through different
PE people that I know to see how it fit
with them and I identified in my mind
that there's basically two PE groups of
people there the ones that are aware of
their cycle you know and whether they've
acted to change it or they're just
reliving it who knows and the ones that
are totally unaware that they're in this
cycle and they just think oh God the my
luck you know they say phrases like that
just my luck how does one increase their
awareness of their own cycle do you
think there's a way yes um so much that
can be done let's imagine the very
simplest exercise psychologists have
these things called sentence completion
tests where you start with a stub of a
question and then you end it with an
ellipses a dot dot dot and you say to
somebody don't think too much just
finish the sentence and typical ones are
men are dot dot dot women are dot dot
dot I am dot dot dot life dot dot dot
now if you give somebody that sheet of
paper and say to them don't think too
much as just write it down all right
amazing things Bubble Up men are you
know authoritarian villains wow where
did that come from right you're carrying
out you know women are you know whatever
it is life you know I am you know a
nobody who deserves to be stamped did
you know a minute ago that you have that
in you not necessarily in other words
sometimes you need these little levers
to shine a light now the thing that
really Happ helps and I'm not you know
for your viewers um many therapists many
psychotherapists are not what they
should be uh but some are great if you
find yourself with a good
psychotherapist they can also increase
your level of self-awareness I think
that's what we're talking about
increasing level of self-awareness and
and the reason is very simple you know
there's stuff that we all do let's
imagine I don't know when you're around
a man you think that person's judging me
therefore I'm going to withdraw and not
enter into competition with them I'm
around a woman I think I'm going to have
to you know I'm going to be treated
badly therefore I you know whatever it
is something from your past is projected
onto it you end up in a therapy room
with a man or a woman and lo and behold
what do you do you bring out that thing
and you bring out that thing that you're
doing normally except this time you're
not doing it in the office you're not
doing it in a relationship you're not
doing it in a context where people are
busy and have' got their own stuff going
on and doing their own games you're
doing it with somebody a trained
professional in a quiet room and they
can see it's like a pety dish they can
see the stuff that you're doing and so
suddenly you'll be saying to your
therapist I know you hate me and the
therapist will be
going I I really don't think so but I'm
interested that you have that conviction
that you do um or someone will be going
to the therapist I need to look after
you I think you're quite tired and I
really you know you've been doing such
great work I feel I want to look after
you
maybe you'd been doing that all your
life and the therapist will be going you
don't need to look after me but was
there someone in your past that you
needed to look after and that made you
feel guilty and that has meant that
every time you're with somebody you feel
that their needs are more important than
your needs and there's a chance
therefore to see more clearly than ever
before outside of the kind of hubub of
relationships or office life the kind of
stories that you're projecting onto
reality to your huge cost
so I'm now aware of my cycle that
originates from my childhood the next
step is doing something about it how do
I overpower that sort of hardwired urge
to repeat the cycle that comes from my
childhood well look Stephen let's not
minimize that's already an enormous
achievement you know what I mean I mean
that's that's if you know if you're
there that you have a handle on look we
don't need people to be perfect right we
don't need people to be perfect
at best we need people to know how
they're imperfect and that they can have
a chance to warn us of their
imperfections in good time before
they've done too much damage there's an
enormous difference I mean look again
take the take the dating idea let's
imagine you know I often
say don't do this to me because we're
not um we're not under a date but um but
a great question to ask somebody on a
date is how are you mad how are you mad
right if the person says I'm not mad I'm
completely sane run away because you
know everybody has folly inside them and
we're approaching a measure of everyday
tolerable sanity when we've put some
Flags in the areas of our Madness so
total sanity is not a possibility for
any human being um but the awareness of
where the insanity lies and a little bit
of warning and prompt apology you know
after um an incident ENT goes a huge
long way you know people often say I'm
looking for a partner with a good sense
of humor no one needs jokes it's not
it's not about jokes it's really about
modesty about oneself right somebody
who's able to go I think I mean look
take the other thing if you meet
somebody who thinks they're easy to live
with run away no one's easy to live with
and someone who thinks they're easy to
live with is really trouble so somebody
who can put out the hand go you know
what yeah I'm bit of I'm pretty tricky
to to to live with great that person is
safer not necessarily totally safe but
they're safer because they've started on
the road to
self-awareness and so ultimately the
best we can do in this world is
self-awareness prompt apologies when we
slip up um yeah and a genuine intention
to uh make progress I guess is that is
that important as well so like me being
aware that I have certain habits in my
relationship is one thing but then I
think my partner would like to know that
some of the destructive Cycles I might
have I'm working on them I'm I'm I'm at
least trying to make Forward Motion yeah
totally I mean I think one of the most
destructive ideas in the modern world is
the idea that true love means accepting
somebody for who they are in all of
their you know all of their good and bad
sides it's a it's a lovely dream and you
know sometimes when you hear of breakups
they'll go you know my ex you know they
just didn't accept me for who I was and
everyone will go oh yes God what a
terrible person you know how you know
politely one wants to go hang on a
minute do any of us really deserve to be
loved for the whole of who we are is
that really a fair expectation or isn't
as you suggest isn't it fairer to
suppose that all of us are Works in
progress and that you know there is
nothing contrary to the spirit of love
in a desire to improve the ancient
Greeks had this right you know for the
ancient Greeks Plato saw love as a
classroom beautiful idea love is a
classroom in which two people in a
spirit of generosity and kindness I mean
we're not talking about shouting here
we're talking about generosity and
kindness two people Endeavor to help
each other to become the best version of
themselves of each other right the that
love is is geared towards progress and
working on yourself that sounds very odd
nowadays you know if you if you went
around saying I've read some Plato and
uh he's kind of guiding me towards the
idea that love is a classroom so
therefore I'm going to give you a
40-minute lecture on some of your flaws
and then I'd like you to give me a
40-minute lecture on some of my flaws
this would be considered ding ding ding
unromantic right that's not very
romantic is it doesn't mean it's a bad
idea as I say love is a skill to be
learned not just an emotion to be felt
and some of that means that we might
need to go back to school I've been
thinking more recently that most
relationships the success of most
relationship comes down to this idea of
like how good you are at conflict
resolution because I've had a previous
relationship where um we we both can
take the the blame per se we were just
not good at conflict resolution and then
I've had a more recent relationship
where we're very we seem to be much
better not perfect but much better at
conflict resolution and it makes all the
difference and but I think St you know
it's not if you were bad at conflict
resolution it's not just your fault it's
it's partly the way our society Works
come back to the idea of Romanticism
right Romanticism gives us this
extraordinary idea that love is
something that should be felt and
communicated without words right so the
most romantic people thing the most
romantic sentence that often people will
say is I met this person and we didn't
even need to speak we just felt on the
same page everyone goes oh how romantic
ding ding danger um because it's you
know well this leads to a catastrophic
outbreak of sulking right what is sulk
suling right a what is a sulk a sulk is
a fascinating pattern of behavior where
you get very angry with someone because
they have not understood you without
even though you haven't said anything
they've not understood you and you get
offended because you think because
you're a romantic person you think they
can't possibly love me because true love
means understanding somebody you know
intuitively um wordlessly and therefore
I'm not going to speak and so you know
you're coming back from a party with
your with your partner and uh they say
to you is anything wrong darling and you
go mm of course there is but you're not
going to tell them and then they start
saying come on you can tell me what's
wrong and and the sulking person goes no
and this can go on and on and on I mean
you know we're all we've all been at it
some sometimes you know you you go home
uh you go straight upstairs you go to
the bathroom you shut the door and then
your partner's kind of knocking at the
door going please darling just just tell
me what's wrong and you go from behind
the door no and and the reason is that
you're a romantic and you believe that
your partner should have miraculous
almost alien capacities to look through
the bathroom door into your nared and
wounded soul to understand what the
upset is but of course they can't
because they're just human you know
takes us a long time to realize that
other humans are not mind readers you
know one of the first thing we should
always ask is have I told them this I I
know I'm upset but did I tell them this
and so often the answer is not quite
because we're Romantics and so we have
to do that really I mean you know we can
accept it's really boring we've got to
use words we got to painfully stack up
words and go the reason that I'm getting
a little tety is because and you got to
explain yourself it's not very romantic
but that is normally a sign it's a good
idea so honesty I I've struggled at
times to be completely honest in my
relationships when I felt like the
honesty might hurt
them
so can we have true love
and total honesty I believe that the the
wish to tell someone absolutely
everything is is both beautiful and
ultimately utopian in a problematic way
because we all of us have within us
ambivalences doubts um Unfaithful
thoughts Etc and it isn't the work of
love to rub your partner constantly up
against the most troubling Disturbed
sides of your psyche now we're not
talking this is not an advocacy for sort
of total mendacity and lies but it is an
advertisement for
editing you know we should hope that we
don't meet the fullest version of each
other all the time you know I know it
sounds romantic but sometimes it's you
as parents know is it is it that great
as a parent to tell your child
absolutely everything about what's going
through you or sometimes you know is
there a role for saying I'm just going
to edit myself not in the name of subu
or deceit but in the Name of Love That
love could be compatible with an editing
of certain aspects of your reality one
of the areas where a lot of editing
happens is in the
bedroom in relationships in sex in
sexless
relationships um I was looking through
some statistics earlier on because I
know that you've talked quite um
extensively on relationships and sex and
sexless relationships I found this stat
that says a 2022 study by relate to UK
based uh counseling Network found that
26% of people in relationships were
having sex less than 10 times per year
and 8% we're having no sex at all this
is a stark rise from
2018 um where the numbers were quite
significantly lower than that it seems
like as a society we're getting
increasing ly
sexless yeah so the question is where's
the problem is the problem in the body
or is the problem in the mind now you
know being the kind of guy I am I'm
going to shift us to the mind I'm sure
sometimes there are bodily issues and
you know they deserve attention too but
if I can talk about the mind um why is
it that sex is easier at the beginning
than in a long-term
relationship one of the leading answers
is
anger it's not very easy to have sex or
want sex with someone that you're angry
with and in many relationships there's a
lot of stored anger that neither party
knows is there and that anger has come
from micro incidents of disappointment
someone didn't quite call when they said
they would someone didn't laugh when
they might have done someone didn't show
generosity when it might have been
required um and these things get stored
up and the result of too much of this is
that you don't want someone going
anywhere near you cont because you're
because you're Furious you're
essentially Furious but in the way of
these things you don't know you are you
don't know you're Furious again you know
the mind is not obvious to itself so you
know if you want to have more sex don't
just invest in candles and fancy linen
um a quite useful thing to do is to go
and have dinner with your partner and
say to
them we're both going to ask each other
how we've annoyed each other because we
have annoyed each other not because
we're evil people but because we're
human and we're in a relation ship and
no relationship survives more than an
hour without a buildup of frustration
and the more we can let out that
frustration at the dinner table the more
it won't you know create a blockage in
the bedroom and so the chance to
discharge frustration and you know often
the reason why we don't tell our
partners what our frustrations are is
that they sound ridiculous it's like
well hang on you're upset with me
because I use the word really in what
you thought placed too much emphasis on
the why when I was speaking to your
mother are you crazy right you could you
are laying yourself open to your partner
pointing to you going are you crazy but
I think that we're all in love very
small children at least a small part of
us is and um as we know small children
get upset about really weird tiny things
you know you'll move a button and they
start wailing and you go what's happened
and they go you moved a button and you
go I did uh why does that matter but for
them it matters or you know pencil has
slightly changed Direction so we should
learn we should remember what it felt
like to be a child and we should
acknowledge that there remains even in
an adult who's very competent in all
sorts of areas a small child who is
liable to be getting very upset about
small things triggered triggered but
because they're an adult this is the
problem we we think well an adult can't
possibly be having such childish
reactions again we need to just um cast
aside our fears of Shame and say you
know what yes an adult can can get very
upset about tiny things an adult
probably is upset about tiny things and
we're doing ourselves an honor when we
can dare to reveal this to our partner
and they can do likewise so if I'm if if
I'm someone listening to this now and
I'm in a relationship where I don't
think because it's interesting even when
I say I don't think I'm having enough
sex the idea of how much sex is enough
sex has probably come from movies which
is a bit of a trap as well right um but
if I'm in a relationship and we are in a
sexless relationship by what a
definition Solution One you presented
there is try and resolve the anger the
underlying contempt um are there
anything else that you think is
effective ways of solving for that look
I think we I think one useful thing to
do is to go why does sex matter what is
this thing called sex why why does it
matter and when people get very upset I
think the answer tends to be that sex is
a symbol of something very poignant and
very delicate which is my partner loves
me and they can't the reason why it
becomes such an acute issue is that they
cannot hold on to the idea that the
partner might love them and might not
want sex this is psychologically
impossible now it is important to say it
is possible it is possible that your
partner both loves you and doesn't want
to have sex there could be other reasons
they're feeling unwell so and and then
we can ask ourselves what does sex
really aim at sex aims at intimacy you
know even we'll say they you know in in
in in people polite language I say they
became intimate which means they had sex
so what what we know about sex is that
the really exciting thing about sex is
not the sex bit it's the intimate bit um
it's the idea that someone is without
their guard you know most of the time we
approach other people with our guards on
and um in this very rare and unusual
thing we do we meet another human being
in a vulnerable state and this is such a
relief from the normal limitations of
life and there are other ways of doing
this you know sex is not the only way of
doing it so by understanding better what
sex is we can also have a chance to get
some of what we get in sex in things
that are not sex if that makes sense I
had Tracy Cox on the podcast and she
said something to me which really stuck
with me because I hadn't noticed it
until she said it which is this idea I
believe she called otherness which is
when your partner almost becomes like a
family member
or you start seeing them as like a a
sibling because they are in their
sweatpants around you and she made the
claim which I think I've read in your
books as well that in many respects
that's the very opposite of the the
spice that makes sex so appealing in
those early days when it's new and novel
and risky you know and so she kind of
alluded to the fact that love and sex
were actually sit on two different ends
of a pole right and again come back to
my theme um what do the romantic say a
romantic Romanticism tells us sex and
love belong entirely together but I
think what you're saying and you know
what many of your viewers will know is
that the relationship is is trickier and
again let's not torture ourselves about
this let's let's get curious and then
let's communicate about this um and I
think that look a growing child has a
paradox to deal with and this is what
Freud famously doesn't matter what you
think of Freud it's very useful
observation really that um the child
experiences love in the first instance
at the beginning of Life we all
experience love um at the hands of
people who everything's gone right we
will have no sexual connection with
right so given the debt that adult love
owes to Childhood um that sets us up
with a problem when we as adults start
to fall in love with people and start to
build up relationships which is that the
more we get cozy with someone the more
we feel like we did a little bit with
our parents when things were really cozy
which is oddly why um people like going
to hotels why do people like going to
hotels to revive a relationship it's cu
the furniture doesn't remember you the
curtains don't remember you you are
you're allowed to be for a chosen moment
somebody without the history and it's
the history that is making intimacy hard
because that history while it's knitting
you together and making you emotionally
close is also
rendering sexual Freedom problematic and
I think it's just we need to go very
easy on ourselves for the fact that this
happens and um what do we do about it
though um do I need to book a lot of
hotel rooms do I need to spend a lot of
time away from my partner I noticed even
that you're laughing you're smiling as
you say that and I think that's partly
the CL you know when we come up against
the hardest conundrums in in life um
having the tolerance of a sense of humor
a shared sense of humor you know if a
couple can turn the sexual challenges
from a tragedy into something you know
closer to um a comedy it's an enormous
achievement think of you know think of
teasing right there are sides of couples
that they find really really hard isn't
it wonderful when a couple learns with
affection to tease one another they go
ah Stephen yeah there's that thing that
you do it gives you a little nickname
calls you whatever it is you know a
little affectionate nickname that's a
wonderful moment because it means that
irritation has been sublimated into
tender compassionate understanding for
why someone is as difficult as they are
so the best thing we can do with our
irritations with our partners is to be
able to tease our way out of them um and
we may need to do this in Troublesome
areas like uh like sex it's an enormous
achievement if your partner can call you
you know can go from thinking that you
are an idiot to smiling at you and
thinking you're a lovable idiot right
we're all in the end of the day a
lovable idiot we don't need to believe
in God but if God was watching us from
up there on the space station um we are
all you know 8 billion lovable idiots
and once we can have that sort of
compassionate relationship to ourselves
that's the beginning of a big pit of the
big bit of the solution I often think
you know I've been in my relationship
now for a couple of years I have think
how do I stop my partner getting bored
of me will there become a day sometimes
it does cross my mind like is she just
going to get like bored of me and also
you know vice versa you think of being
with someone for like 40 50 60 years I'm
sure some people listening have been
with their partners for multi- decades
is there a risk of us getting bored of
our partner and then seeking the sort of
you know the novelty in Affairs and how
do we prevent that okay well look here's
one suggestion um the thing that becomes
very very boring in all relationships is
when people cease to listen to each
other now you know when you when you say
the word listen you got to think oh yeah
yeah I know what that means hang on
let's complicate this issue a little bit
usefully um to you know most of us have
never been listened to properly it's not
something that normally we know how to
do we know how to speak you know there
are there are there are lessons in how
to become a good public speaker not very
many lessons in how to become a good
listener right that telling us something
um so what is it to listen imagine a
situation where someone says something
to you and rather than you jumping in
going oh that reminds me of you know
something happened with my auntie or
that reminds me of or you know starting
to give advice and going the thing that
you need to remember is 1 2 3 4 right
which is normally what we do when people
speak is to Simply hold back and
therapists are good at doing this and
simply do what they call reflexive
listening so you know you say to
somebody um I'm really annoyed I've had
such a difficult day at work this
happened that happened that happen and
then you simply repeat back to them
using slightly different words the
essence of what they've said and you say
I'm hearing that life's quite difficult
for you at the moment at work and that
you you know coming under pressure from
your boss and the person you know it'll
be try it because the person will
immediately feel I'm being heard and
then they will have they will feel more
they understand more about themselves
you know why is it that in the company
of some people we feel really
interesting and have lots to say and in
the company of others we kind of feel
bit bored we don't have anything to say
we're the same people it's because we
feel we Ure it that we're in the
presence of a listener
and the best way to listen is literally
to not give advice not um give anecdotes
but repeat back to somebody what they've
said in slightly different words and I
mean you know parents bless them I've
been a parent we' all been parents many
of us been parents um parents are often
quite bad at listening to their children
they think they're listening I I was in
a um holiday
Resort a few months ago and there was
this kid little kid must have been three
for and it was having a bad day it was
really screaming and the parent the
mother was say might be the mother
someone was saying um what's what's
wrong um and the kid was saying I hate
it here the whole place smells um it's a
poo and I want to be back home at
kindergarten and the caregiver said
don't be so silly darling we're on
holiday holidays are fun and what's more
this hotel has cost a lot of money and
you want to go okay I get it this woman
was trying to help she was trying to you
know calm down this this distressed
child was she listening not really
because basically what the kid was
saying is I'm having a really bad day
Everything feels absolutely disastrous
help me ah right and we're all we all
have a version of those days and we
don't want to be told come on you're
living in really wonderful times the sun
is shining you know uh there's lots to
celebrate we want someone to
go I hear things are bad for you I'm
hearing things are bad for you um I'm
hearing you're not coping very
well and you're pretty
sad now if you do that don't rush them
don't give advice don't give you know
you will get a great response back we
can put money on
it
listening what are the um the other core
components then because I really want to
close off this topic on love and sexless
relationships what would you say are the
core components or the core habits of
two people who have a really successful
long-term enduring sexual and romantic
relationship if we just focus on the
this the sex side of things first what
are those core habits so I guess
Communications when that's come through
quite loudly look I'd start a little bit
further upstream and go like overall
what do these guys need to do and I
think overall they both need to
acknowledge that they are frail fragile
slightly crazy people because not
because they are them but because
they're human and there's no other
option for a human being than to be
slightly crazy and nevertheless against
that background they're attempting to do
their best right so that the combination
of an acknowledgement of their fallible
nature mixed in with um a dedication to
trying to understand it through broadly
therapeutic means so this is a very
crucial thing the other absolutely
crucial thing is an acknowledgement that
a lot of what people will be getting up
to in relationships will have nothing to
do with the person in front of you that
you will be importing from different
periods of your life scenarios and
assumptions that owe nothing to the here
and now and owe quite a lot to Mom Dad
caregivers and other scenarios and the
capacity to acknowledge that with grace
to say okay I'm sorry I'm you know I'm
getting confused about who's in front of
me right I importing into this situation
an energy that doesn't belong there we
all do this the whole basis of
attachment Theory let's remind ourselves
is that your attachment style is
governed by your first attachment the
attachment that you had with a parental
figure and therefore you know you will
be let's say insecurely preoccupied
attached to somebody um not because they
deserve that quality of attachment
because your early caregiver did that's
that's what they mandated through their
own behavior but your partner maybe
someone completely different is someone
completely different so if I can put it
this way getting on top of your
projections we project wildly as human
beings and being able to have at least a
sense that the person in front of you
may not be entirely who you think they
are and that reality in the here and now
may be slightly more innocent um and I
think you know you owe it to yourself
it's look it's so boring I'm sorry
Stephen I'm sorry to your listeners you
have to get on top of your childhood
it's so boring to be told this to be to
be 30 40 50 60 and to be told that you
have to get on top of your childhood I
mean my goodness this is not a Nostalgia
Fest the only reason is so you can put
the damn thing to bed and never have to
think about it again but it's going to
be rattling around unless you have done
so and I think it's so look think of
language all of us when we were kids we
were put in an environment where without
us doing anything we learned an entire
language with syntax grammar complicated
vocabulary Etc and this happened while
we were doing handstands in the garden
drawing buttercups in the kitchen Etc we
absorbed an entire language and we had
no idea the same thing was going on
emotionally we learned an emotional
language not a language about grammar
and vocabulary but a language about
trust a language about self-esteem a
language about who we are a language
about what will happen to us when we
trust someone a language about whether
it's safe to go with someone to be
ourselves Etc we learned that whole
language and we have no idea we learned
it just that we have no idea we ever
learned our language of birth it just
happened but it's inside us no less than
the grammatical language and what we
have to do and it's just as difficult as
learning in adulthood you know how
difficult it is imagine if I said to you
learn Finnish now now you're going to
learn Finnish or next week we're going
to go off and we're going to learn you
know I don't know Korean right you'd be
like in a week uh well it's going to
take a long time isn't it we're GNA have
to do this for a long time do you know
what I'd say there's two things I'd
reply if you told me to end Finish first
one is God that's gonna this is what I
think that's going to take forever and
the second one is what's the point but
I'd also say let's say we're not trying
to learn Finnish we're trying to learn
trust let's say we're not trying to
learn Korean we're trying to learn the
lesson of vulnerability safe
vulnerability right these are very
valuable lessons very valuable lessons
that we need in our relationships I say
that because I I point at the childhood
patterns that you're talking about and I
think one of the reasons why people
don't open up that closet and do the
work there is because they don't realize
that that is the Puppet Master dictating
their career relationships and
everything in between so I think Step
One is like them understanding the
impact that that childhood narrative is
having today yeah and and then also
realizing you know this is where
language can be a useful metaphor is is
about time because sometimes people say
okay so I I understand and I saw listen
to a podcast a great great guy um
Stephen you know really gets on top of
it listen to many of his podcasts
problem is after three podcast I'm not
healed and you want to go look how many
lessons of finish or Korean did you do
or three are you fluent uh not quite I
might need another
150 150 more well in other words we need
to take it slowly and we need to repeat
these things you know we talking about
religion earlier one of things about
religions is they understand that our
minds are like cives you know take Islam
Islam wants us to remember their God
three four five times a day in many
religions you're on your knees
constantly because they know these
religions know that it goes in one a it
goes out the other it comes you know
that that we're not very good at holding
on to the even the truths that we are
most attached to and I think part of the
problem with the modern world is we tend
to think I'll just listen to that idea
once I'll just read an interesting book
said said something to me once and and
I'm going to change my life you want to
go no no you know again think of the
Holy books how many times you supposed
to read the Bible the Quran it's a
Buddhist textt every day because we're
not very good at holding on even to the
things on which Our Lives depend is
there a risk though in this sort of
healing culture where we're all just
healing forever and we're all kind of
like broken and trying to recover from
our early years where someone snatched
candy out of our hands or something is
there I read an article a couple of
weeks ago and it said there was a bit of
a bit of a risk to this long-term
ongoing healing mentality that we're
look I I sense your frustration and I
share it it would be so nice if we could
just get on with life without having to
bother with all this stuff I I
understand but I think Stephen the thing
you have to bear in mind is we are no
longer merely trying to survive we're
trying to thrive right the age of
survival is behind us you know we're not
just looking to reach the age of 30 and
then collapse into bed and thinking you
know it's been fantastic life I've not
been butchered by an enemy right you
know we want to reach 80 85 and we want
not just survival we want fulfillment
and if we want that we're going to have
to pay attention to things that previous
generations didn't again let me use
another metaphor right um for most of
human history people here I am drinking
glass of water right um people didn't
pay much attention to water if it looked
like there wasn't anything actively
floating in it like a frog or something
they'd think it's was clean water right
I just gulp it back and through such
nonchalance if I can put it that way
millions of people died okay and then
towards the end of the 19th century at
about the very same time that Sigman
Freud in Vienna was getting going
helping us to think about certain things
in the psyche various people got very
interested in water supply and all the
main cities Paris London New York got a
complete overhaul of their water
supplies because it was suddenly
discovered that microscopic organisms
could kill hundreds of thousands of
people in a glass of water that looked
completely clear you might have enough
to kill a city right and this is deeply
perplexing you think hang on a minute
it's just a glass of water must be fine
and you know I don't want to be hard on
you but in that tone of like really is
could we be bothered with that old
childhood stuff why don't we just get on
with it you want to go
unfortunately we have to take care
because there are
macrobiotic organisms as it were in our
lives that are gumming up our capacities
for fulfillment and it's not that it's
not necessarily they're going to kill us
but they will hamper our capacity to be
you to exploit our full potential and
after all you know this is what this
podcast is about this is what many
people are concerned about and it's
going to require work can we ever truly
heal from those things can or will they
always be there in the back room just
exerting less power over us um look
wonderful German philosopher
schopenhauer he says that the goal of
life is to turn tears into knowledge
wonderful progress tears what what are
you going to do with those they just end
up in your pillow they might end up you
know being uh things you can learn from
so I think the best we can do is to
learn to turn so many of the troubles
that afflict us you know no life is
without Affliction but that moment when
we go you know what I've learned
something from this torment this was a
total nightmare but I've pulled out of
it something about myself about human
nature about psychology then we're
really learning then we're really on the
path to a good life because a good life
is not a problematic free life it's a
life in which we've found a way of
learning from our inevitable pains you
will never find the right person I read
that sentence and that sounded a little
bit um negative I think I read it in
your book you'll never find the right
person well I was teasing gently our old
Friends The Romantics who tell us that
of course we will find the right person
and the belief in the right person has
led to more rage more disappointment
more frustration than any other you know
if you tell people you will find the
right person and if you build up a model
of what it will mean to find the right
person you will be dooming people to
disappointment if for example they meet
somebody who's really good many ways
very very good but they've had an
argument with them well oh I'm not
supposed to argue with somebody that is
the right person we're supposed to be
Bliss Blissful so I'm teasing really the
concept of rightness rightness can
include a lot of wrongness and that's
why you know Wonderful English psycho
analyst Donald winot who came up with
this phrase a good enough he applied it
to Parenthood he he argued that no child
needs a perfect parent indeed it's quite
dangerous to have a perfect parent
because you never leave home quite good
to have a parent who causes you few
frustration it'll it'll get you out
there um but he argued no one needs a
perfect parent no one needs a perfect
lover they need a good enough parent a
good enough
lover do you think um that people that
are in relationships romantic
relationships should spend time
apart do you think that's healthy for
the stuff we've talked about with
sexlessness and stuff cuz I think I I
tend to get more excited about sex with
my partner when she's been away for a
while and there's a real novelty to it
yes look I think one of the things that
distance can do is to remind you that
there is no pre-ordained reason why
someone should be with you I mean it's
one of the most miraculous things that
anyone should choose to be with anyone
because anyone is a quite complicated
proposition and some of the mystery of
that um can kind of you know achieve its
necessary Force after a a a period away
look it's like being very ill imagine
being ill for a while you've been you've
not been in the world for very long um
for a while suddenly you're feeling
better you go out into the world you go
to the park and suddenly oh my God
there's this thing called a tree it's
amazing it's got leaves there are some
bugs crawling all over there's something
called grass there's a brick wall you
are suddenly like a three-year-old full
of appreciation and wonder and one of
the great challenges of life is how to
keep being people who have Wonder in in
their life because habit swallows
everything up you oh yeah tree yeah yeah
I I know what those are I know what a
tree is like that's why we need art you
know for example I mean what's the point
of art small topic let's bite that one
off too what's the point of art well one
of the things that happens when you go
to one of these places called galleries
or museums is they're full of paintings
by people who look at the world as
though they've never seen it before
maybe it's their wife or husband they
look at their wife or husband as though
they've never seen them before alone and
behold quite an amazing thing wow it's
going of amazing it's full of tenderness
and beauty and compassion and interest
wow I could you know I could like this
person they look at a tree they look at
a cloud they look at the grass and you
know we are part of what makes children
small children so fascinating but also
frustrating is you suggest to walk to
the park it takes them an hour and a
half to go to the park why because
everything's interesting what have we
done with those layers of interest that
we also used to possess we think we know
what's going on but but we don't um and
one of the wonderful things that
children can remind us is the
foreignness the true foreignness of a
world that we feel we know we feel we've
seen but we haven't actually looked
at you say on page 75 of that book that
the solution to long-term sexual
stagnation is to learn to see our lover
as if we had never laid eyes on him or
her before it feels so natural though
that through this process of sort of
habituation everything in our lives
becomes less uh yields less Joy than it
once did and I and I I often fight with
that because you know as things get
financially more uh as you get more
financially free in life you're able to
experience the the you know the nice
restaurants and the nice things and the
nice holidays and the nice planes all
those kinds of things um but with that
the awe and the surprise escapes you
absolutely and I think we need to work
at it the Buddhists were onto this um
the wonderful Buddhist scroll from the
Middle Ages medieval scroll uh six
personman
you know personman kind of fruit um it's
got bit like an apple um uh and it's
just six pans on a on a canvas beautiful
rendition and the idea is that the
Buddhist Sage is meant to look at those
six pmans for an hour the true one could
could keep going for even a day right
just six persans right and you might go
hang on a minute can I change the
channel please can I look at something
else the capacity to stare intensely at
something and draw benefit from it is
absolutely something that we lose as
especially as life gets more more
dizzying the the thing to bear in mind
is life can ever only be so exciting
it's not by more stimulation that you
ever if your senses are wrecked if
you're unable to draw benefit from one
lemon having a thousand lemons or a
sports car isn't going to make you more
of an appreciator the goal is to learn
to appreciate more of what we've already
seen and that is you know we talk about
gym and exercises and and and workouts
it's something we need to do I mean it's
it's literally learning to see into
appreciate is a skill um and you can
dial it up or dial it down and as I say
one of the good things about works of
art is there are records of careful
looking by people they might not be
looking at things you're looking at but
it's less about what you're looking at
that it's a method of looking that you
can learn from as you'll know if you've
listened to this podcast before I'm an
investor in a company called hu I'm on
their board and they sponsor this
podcast and I have a very exciting
announcement to make this product called
Daily Greens is one of the most highly
requested products at H but it's never
been sold in the UK before
until now it's often difficult to get
all of the greens into our diet that we
need to have a healthy gut microbiome
and a healthy body and with hu's Daily
Greens product with one scoop every
morning a very very delicious scoop you
can get 91 vitamins minerals and Whole
Food sourced nutrients into your diet
the most important Point here is I
genuinely believe it tastes delicious
it's May my favorite heal product ever
for all the reasons I've described so if
you want access to this product you can
sign up right now the link is in the
description below it launches in the UK
in January because of the demand I'm
pretty sure it's going to sell out a
therapeutic Journey lessons from the
school of Life the Sunday Times
bestselling author of the school of life
I've seen this book everywhere um I walk
into bookshops all the time and I just
wish my book had the prominence
it does I saw I yeah I was in a foils
the other day and I think you've got
some signed copies in there I picked up
one yeah um why why did you write a book
called A therapeutic Journey um because
I have to
say you you have
written lots and lots bit too much a lot
of books I mean this is not even half of
them no there's about 70 of them yeah
this book a therapeutic Journey um it's
really following the art
of what one could call mental breakdown
or a mental a mental crisis from the
moment of its Inception the moment it
strikes us through to the moment of
recovery and then I go into lots of
byways and lots of uh you know lots of
digressions but essentially it's saying
how can we keep our minds safe how can
we help them to heal um what can we do
when we are in a mental crisis it's
written in a tone I hope of sympathy um
of kindness and also trying to give
people a sense of what's happening to me
because very often you know when when
there is a breakdown we don't know what
on Earth's going on you know yesterday
we were happy go-lucky now we can't get
out of bed yesterday we were able to
hold it together now everything that
comes out of our mouth makes no sense so
I think that the um uh it's it's it's
supposed to be a companion through what
might be some of our loneliest hours why
do we need this book right now do you
think in society I think because look I
hope that people will think hm okay this
is written from a place of somebody who
probably gets what what they're saying
and what I'm feeling I think we need
companions through things that probably
feel very personal but are actually this
is the good news very general but I
think you know at the school of life we
see so many people who are going through
these things and the thing that each one
thinks is I'm alone and the best thing
you can say to people is say no you're
not and the reason they think they alone
is that you know it's a paradox of human
beings we only know people from what
they choose to tell us but we know our
own minds from introspection and so
there's a massive sort of cognitive gap
between self- knowledge and knowledge of
others and in that Gap shame develops
right and um there's so much shame
around mental illness because it's still
as we know so rarely spoken about and so
the book aims to rehabilitate to educate
and to
comfort this is a book about getting
unwell imagining that we have let
everyone down and losing Direction and
hope it's also a book about Redemption
about re gaining the thread
rediscovering meaning and finding a way
back to connection warmth and
joy what are the ways in which we're
unwell increasingly well you know it's
very hard when your mind is operating
well you almost don't notice what it's
doing doing because it's doing so many
things to keep you feeling you know we
even have that word normal right how do
you feel I feel normal yeah that's
that's my Baseline that's just that's
just how I am it's it's the result of we
could call it gifts because when those
gifts are taken away Goodness Me do you
notice right so for example there's
something in our mind in a
well-functioning mind that more or less
keeps us on our side right there would
be so many reasons for all of us to
despair of who we are you know why would
I be on why would I be on my side I've
made mistakes I'm not perfect Etc but
most of us you know on a on a good day
you Steven will go look I'm not perfect
but you know I'm okay I can keep going
when you're mentally unwell that that
faculty breaks down and suddenly you
can't abide your own self you can't
forgive yourself you know there are
people who are unwell who will say 17
years ago I said something to someone
and I can't forgive myself and you want
to go that's 17 years ago it's okay and
they can't let it go that's what illness
is illness is not being able to let go
of an argument against yourself because
you have turned into Your Own Worst
Enemy um the other thing that that
people manage to do um in in a healthy
mind is bracket things so that not all
the things that could be in your mind
are active in your mind at any point
right so you're able to sequence
thoughts so you think you know well you
know I've got this to do I'm
interviewing this guy now tomorrow I'll
be in New York uh there's also thing
with my granny and there's also thing
with friend Etc but those thoughts are
sequenced you're able to line them up in
in a coherent order when Health breaks
down all of these things come at all
angles there's no Order anymore there's
no hierarchy so something that happened
10 years ago is expressing something is
happening right now um something that's
deeply urgent collides with something
that you know by rational means is not
that urgent but it seems as urgent and
so everything coherent breaks down you
can no longer order things there are
voices that start coming in not friendly
voices all of us have voices in our
minds not necessarily you know they're
not I'm not talking about psychotic
voices but there are voices voices of
encouragement often you can keep going
just just you know do it or it's okay
you could dare to take that risk often
kindly voices that we've Incorporated
from kind people around us when mental
health breaks down we can only hear the
worst voices the voices that are telling
us you don't deserve to be here you've
made a mistake and we don't want you
here anymore better thing would be if
you didn't exist those voices and those
voices don't let up and then we're in
trouble and we need to raise the White
Flag because things are not well and
sometimes we keep going we're so good at
keeping going that it's terrible half
the problem is that we keep going so
well you know we're we're half dead
before we realize there's a problem
right and so the ability to go hang on
hang on I can't take it anymore that is
the beginning of being knowing how to
get help because when the mind is in
trouble what it most needs is another
mind it's like calibration right when
you've lost the correct calibration you
need somebody else to go you know when
you go everyone hates me and it's all
terrible and nothing I've done is of any
value just have another mind that says
okay I know how you feel let's think
about this is is that is that really who
who you are who that that is and then
you know gradually with love and let's
remember people always get mentally
unwell because of love I don't mean
romantic relationships but all mental
unwellness stems somewhere if if you
scroll back there's always a deficit of
love always there's always an experience
of Cruelty in some way that breaks the
mind and when people get well there is
also always an experience of love that
heals and it could be love you know not
romantic love love from a friend love
from a therapist love from professionals
but it's essentially an act of love an
act of love saves us redeems us so the
problem and often the antidote is love
or at least the cause and the antidote
is often love yes imaginatively
understood not merely romantic love and
its broadest sense and you know because
mental breakdown is often emerges from a
buildup of Cruelty an unbearable cruelty
which makes life unbearable for the
person and they then have to you know
project it outwards I mean in when when
illness becomes very severe and you have
a psychosis
you know what can happen is that people
become obsessed with the idea that
everyone is against them the CIA is
against them other people are plotting
against them really what this is an
outgrowth of is an unbearable inner
negativity that hasn't found any way of
being handled you use the word
resilience in this book and I think the
word resilience is often misunderstood
because we think of resilience as like T
it up and you know take it what is your
definition of resilience and why is why
is that such a prominent word in this
book look I think true resilience should
be compatible with things that don't
look resilient at all things that look
very desperate very humble very um
broken indeed so um yes I mean I like
you am suspicious of the use of that
word resilience as as really just
meaning a kind of stoic um bouncing back
from all problems immediately um I I
think it means a generous understanding
of how much madness has a legitimate
claim on even a healthy life um towards
the end of the book I have a little
thing I Riff on about the seasons some
of it is understanding that this is
normal this is part of the natural cycle
not railing against it some of what what
does that help understanding that it's
normal well sometimes when people have
mental troubles uh they will have ups
and downs right and sometimes people can
box themselves in and they'll go I
suffered now I'm better again you know
I'm I'm better and the advice is always
H careful careful that belief that
you're better the rigid belief the past
is behind me the darkness is behind me
can itself start to see kind start that
can itself start to seem like a problem
because it means that you'll be
intolerant towards any regression and
regression belongs to progress just like
dark days belong to Good Seasons you
know we need some of that and and the
natural world has a wonderful way if
we're ATT tune to it of telling us about
Cycles really what we're talking about
cyclicality darkness is followed by
light Autumn is followed by winter is
followed by Spring the mind has its own
seasons and the more we can accept the
legitimacy of those Seasons the less
we'll rail against some of the
necessary sliding into darkness which
for many of us is simply going to be
unavoidable if someone chooses to pick
up this book and they get to the final
page what do you hope they' learned or
taken away from them by getting to the
end of this
book um really real Sympathy for the
complexity of their minds a real
understanding that um It's Not Easy
Being Human that there is nothing
indulgent about you know working on
oneself as you put it that that this
this is a a boring but Al very necessary
task um some tools in there about how to
do it from the very practical to the
more theoretical there's a practical
book about how you can work on the most
broken bits of yourself and find a kind
of equilibrium um but it's also very
deliberately a warm book it's a book of
comfort and I think that something that
we often miss we get we can get a little
too intellectual in this topic thinking
that people who are in trouble um
mentally and just psychologically that
all they need is some ideas you know get
some ideas and yeah sure we need ideas
but you know what we also need is uh
warmth kindness um friendship in a way
now you could say well how could a book
be a friend well you know many of my
best friends are books let me tell you
and um I think it's absolutely in the
remit of of a book to act as a friend
and to say to you very simply You are
not alone you said earlier that a good
conversationalist a good friend a good
romantic partner is someone that makes
you feel heard and understood and I
think that's exactly what you achieve in
this book it is a very difficult thing
to do because books can often feel quite
exclusive especially when the author is
smart as you are um but this book does a
wonderful job of first and
foremost making you realize that the
thing you're going through in the way
that you are isn't evidence of your
inadequacy it's actually evidence that
you are perfectly human and that are you
are like everybody else and through that
lens you can offer support and some very
practical tips about how to you know
endure or rise rise from the situation
that we all find ourselves in in the
different seasons of life that you
describe and that's why it's such an
important important book and that's why
it's done so tremendously well um and
it's being passed around by so many
people Alan thank you so much for for
your time today and thank you for all
your wisdom you're a remarkable talker I
was learning I was watching you and I
was just thinking hell you know
um got a wonderful way to hold people
with the way that you articulate
yourself that is so unbelievably
powerful and uh speaking the art of
speaking is such a important incredible
talent to have and you have that in such
a Wonder way you it's so soothing and
engaging and intelligent and there's a
real poetry to the way that you frame
things which I think is just a
superpower that I would love to have
more of you do Stephen you do no but not
like you have it so it was wonderful
just to learn from the way that you
speak we have we have a closing
tradition on this podcast where the last
guest leaves a question for the next
guest not knowing who they're leaving it
for and the question that's been left
for you
is ah
interesting what was the last thought
thought to keep you awake at
night the last thought to keep me awake
at night um well last night I was quite
worried about coming
here so I was I was kept up but um you
know I'm often kept up I I do I do I do
sleep in in quite a a fragile way and I
think that one of the ways of thinking
about it is that there are thoughts that
happen in the middle of the night that
can't happen at any other time that
there actually some quite important
thoughts often they to do with things
that you didn't even know you were
concerned about but the night teaches
you there is the school of night you
know and and and I used to be very very
impatient um uh Insomniac so I used to
wake up think oh my goodness I can't
believe that I'm still awake how
annoying Etc now I'm thinking maybe
there's something to learn here maybe my
mind's trying to teach me something um
and it might not be anything sort of
totally Earth shatter might not sound
completely Earth shatter but it might
just be something might just be like oh
I really love this thing or I think I
should really steer away from that or
this is really beautiful or whatever it
is something uh a kind of
acknowledgement of the night and so I'm
I've become a better not a better
sleeper but something perhaps even more
important a better
Insomniac why were you uh never staying
up about coming here we're all friendly
people I know you are um I think you
know we've spoken a lot about
expectation haven't we um and and you
know if if your podcast had one listener
um and we were just going down to the
pub that would be so lovely if you
called me up and said we're canceling
the show but we're just going to go to
the pub uh I would have slept like a
baby well you've certainly exceeded All
my expectations and it's a real honor
and a privilege that you chose to come
so thank you so much for that and your
wisdom I'm sure has impacted countless
people not just for the last couple of
decades but even in this conversation
that I guess you'll never get to see so
on behalf of them thank you so much
thanks
Stephen
in 2023 I launched my very own private
Equity Fund called flight fund and since
then we've invested in some of the most
promising companies in the world my
objective is to make this the best
performing Fund in Europe with a focus
on high growth companies that I believe
will be the next European unicorns the
current investors in the fund who have
joined me on this journey are some of
Europe's most successful and Innovative
entrepreneurs and I'm excited to
announce that today as a founder of a
company you can pitch your company to us
or if you are an investor you can also
now apply to invest with us head to
flight fund.com to gain an understanding
of the fund's mission the remarkable
companies we proudly support and to get
in touch with me and my team legal
disclaimer flight fund is regulated by
the FCA so please remember that
investing in the fund is for
sophisticated investors only don't
invest unless you're prepared to lose
all of the money you invest this is a
high-risk investment and you are
unlikely to be protected if something
goes wrong there is no guarantee that
the investment objectives will be
achieved and as with all private Equity
Investments all of the investment
capital is at risk this communication is
for information purposes only and should
not be taken as investment advice or a
financial
promotion do you need a podcast to
listen to next we've discovered that
people who liked this episode also tend
to absolutely love another recent
episode we've done so I've linked that
episode in the description below I know
you'll enjoy it
[Music]
o